j'ai annoncé ma candidature à la
présidence de france télécom qui a des
petites précisions apportées et mais
petite beauté beauté
je vais vous parler mon programme quand
je serai à la tête de france télé à
et le gars le gars prend la grosse tête
à l'avant quand je serai président de
france télé je veux que tous maple
monseigneur une fausse le buzz mais sans
les connais je peux vous dire que je
dormais certains des chroniqueurs avec
moi par exemple j'ai m jean-michel baer
dans l'émission j'irai dormir chez vous
chez vous à sauf que ça s'appellera
j'irai dormir chez vous et je dégagerai
votre première première action en tant
que président je rachète la ligue des
champions ah ouais et aux commentaires
je n'ai jean luc lemoine et gilles
verdez sa femme durant le match psg par
chelsea psg ce soir commentée par les
deux pas eh oui chers téléspectateurs
ici à chelsea c'est vraiment une
ambiance de folie lallaoui république
est tout simplement en fusion c'est le
délire zlatan ibrahimovic russell ballon
mais ils trébuchent
non j'ai bien peur qu'il se soit fait un
croc en jambe avec son poney ça risque
de faire coup franc non mais attendez
j'ai mal à mon coup franc tandis que le
parisien david luiz vient juste de
perdre le ballon dans une zone
dangereuse
il a certainement égaré dans ses cheveux
ce qui risque de lui valoir un penalty
j'ai mal à mon père un tir merci mon
gilles verdez pour ses commentaires
éclairés
j'ai mal à mon commentaire éclairé et si
avec ça on fait pas péter les scores je
comprends pas et c'est pas fini parce
que derrière je mets stéphane bersauter
de qui
bien
elle a toujours quelqu'un pour ne pas
son ca non parce que derrière mes chéris
jeu mais stéphane bern rédacteur en chef
et présentateur de stade 2 à bouge dans
ce créneau stone 2
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
au match aux joueurs plutôt du match
chelsea pg lors du massage de leurs
cornes sûrs et s'occupait alors que
l'huile de camphre semaine à la
transpiration et dégouline le long de
leurs muscles bandés par l'effort comme
j'ai hâte de découvrir les coulisses du
sport non non les coulisses les mêmes
chefs et quand je serai sur france télé
mais chérie je vais aussi rebooster les
programmes du dimanche matin les
émissions religieuses c'est julien
lepers on va s'en occuper for money on
s'installe ce sont 300 candidats plat
as à la messe au nom du père du fils et
du saint-esprit pousse à détruire amen
amen amen amen mes fidèles mais aussi à
la ba à la barre aïd al kabira oui
ajoute au toit oui
radouga roches à la hanche shabbat
shabbat alléluia real à la loi résultats
as we may est à courant une torah est
une bible dans la paix et la fraternité
blocs ou alors quelqu'un de qui a
longtemps quelqu'un petits talons jour
du tigre offre hostile
toi t'as le bonjour 14,2 des grands
attention mais chez m&g à la météo
c'est pas comme ça que le président
après un bel alain mergier et alain
roche et à l'âme et où je fais un casse
et je mets jean marie bigard ça fait un
carton c'est demain jeudi 12 mars il a
fait un temps de merde sur l'ensemble du
territoire
je peux vous dire comment ce pôle et le
jonc les grands donc si vous devez nique
nique et ce soir ce que demain c'est
vrai le grand rétrécissement dans les
calebasses
elle va faire tellement fois qu'on va
assister à une véritable minimath
isation c'est vrai pas avoir besoin
d'une pince à épiler pour aller pêcher
et maintenant mes petits beauté c'est le
clou du spectacle imaginé patrick
sébastien hier on charge de toutes les
interwiew politique du service que grâce
à ses bons c'est génial alors je suis
avec françois hollande
le président alors bon françois qu'est
ce que tu vas nous faire pour l'économie
le chômage puis tout ce bordel qui part
en couille oui je bonjour
pour relancer l'économie je voudrais
sujet du nageur et pour la dette
extérieure de la france
qu'est ce que tu vas n'oublie noyer mon
françois bien je dirais que l'objectif
aujourd'hui plus tard c'est super
j'adore et du coup avec marine le pen
qui se place la question que se posent
les français c est ce que tu as vu
qu'ils ont qu un [ __ ] c'est une des
menaces auraient été trop bon françois
j'adore attention fort soit il ya un
pigeon tu vas te faire chier dessus
qu'est-ce qu'on se bat là je remercie
tous ses cousins par la commission